And again, this next section might be the most important piece about getting better.
I've told many of you that there's five main sub files that we look in
would were attempting to find the cause of a disorder and to help a person
come overcome whatever disorder, whatever sickness they're dealing with,
structural issues, chemistry issues, that's where you're going to find infections
and cancer and things like that. The third one is emotional issues.
That's where we're going to talk about the spiritual emotional sign that is so, so
very important if you're going to get better and even if we're not going to get better
and this is what God has for us is to understand that piece and to really come
to believe that even through whatever I'm dealing with right now,
even through my suffering, even through my struggles, that I can ultimately
bring him glory and I can see the bigger purpose in all of this.
That's really what life is about. We're not promised to live forever here
at Earth and we're promised to have the fullness of our days.
That's all we know what that is. We don't know how many days that is.
This might be my last day right here that I'm sharing with you.
This might be your last day. We just don't know that.
So we need to make everyday count and that's what this little lesson is for.
Is to help us change our mindset so that our mindset is fixed on what is right
and what is good and what is holy and that we can find joy in all things.
In all circumstances, no matter where we find ourselves today.
So this little lesson is unlearning to pray circles.
And I implore you to get this book. If I have copies of this book,
you're going to be going home with one of these books today.
This is the Circle Maker by Mark Batterson.
He's the pastor of National Community Church in Washington, D.C.
is just a great guy and I love all of his work.
So that's what we're going to be talking about.
So what are the ways that we have to change our mindset?
You could say is to change our self-talk and change how we think about ourselves
and changing how we think about ourselves really starts with changing how God
really understands how God thinks about us.
If you have surrendered your life to Him, then you are His child
and He's made you a new creature and all old is passed away and you are new in Him.
And we want to read the Scripture and read the promises that are in Scripture.
If you're struggling with a disorder where you have been given a death sentence
or you feel like you've been given a death sentence,
then these are some things that I want you to start doing.
So there are some action steps that are required in order to change our mind.
So I'm going to give you some hints. This is my challenge to you.
This is your assignment when you go home.
I want you to take some little post-it notes or some little recipe cards
and I want you to write some very meaningful things of these recipe cards.
This is what I do.
So I actually type them out, print them out and laminate them
because I love to laminate things.
It seems like when I laminate something, it makes it permanent for me.
And I carry them around in my little clip-bill fold that I have.
And I read those verses and those little things that mean something to me
that will motivate me to stay focused on the right thing.
I'm going to give you some examples of that through this presentation.
So here's your first example.
This is a verse on a Psalm 118, verse 17.
It says, I shall not die but live and declare the works of the Lord.
This should be your life verse right now if you're struggling with a serious disorder.
You should pray this over yourself constantly.
I shall not die but live.
That would be interesting what it says here.
It doesn't say I shall not die but live so I can have a wonderful life and enjoy my grandkids.
I'm not saying that's not important.
It doesn't say I shall not die but live so that I can have everything that I want
and go on my dexification.
I'm not saying that's not important either.
But our whole purpose is stated in the second part of this verse
that we could be a glory to our Heavenly Father.
So I shall not die but live and declare the works of the Lord.
I want to be a testimony to Him,
but a testimony to Dr. Conner's methods,
not a testimony to my willpower, not a testimony to chemotherapy.
I want to be a testimony to my Heavenly Father so that He gets the glory in everything.
And that's really what my life, my heart, I want to have.
I want to be a testimony whether it be a life or death that I'm a testimony.
No matter what circumstances I find myself in,
but I do want to live so that I can share His Word with other people.
Write those verses down.
He'll be, O Lord, and I shall be healed, say me,
and I shall be saved for you are by praise.
This is a prayer verse from Jeremiah.
Write these down.
For I will restore health to you and heal all your wounds as the Lord.
Another prayer verse from Jeremiah.
This is a promise that we're going to circle,
that we're going to highlight, that we're going to eliminate,
that we're going to put in our pocket,
and we're going to pray circles around.
This is my prayer.
I'm going to pray circles around this.
We're talking about praying.
Circles are praying circles around everything in our life.
What is it that the Lord has called us to?
How are we following Him purposefully?
And then I'm going to start praying for those that I'm not going to let go
until I see them in my life.
Make the heart of this, make people dull in their ears,
and shut their eyes, lest they see with their eyes,
and hear with their ears, understand with their heart,
and return and be healed.
So this is a reverse prayer.
Now let's turn around and say, Lord, open up my ears,
open up my eyes so that I can see your ways.
I don't want to fall into this category where the people are dulled.
They can't see your truth.
I want to see your truth.
Show me your purposes.
I need your healing.
I need your touch.
I need to be on the other side of this verse.
The Spirit of the Lord is upon me because the Lord has anointed me
to preach good things to the poor.
He has set me to heal the broken hearted,
and proclaim liberty to the captives,
and the opening of the prison to those who are bound.
Now this is written in Isaiah,
but this is exactly what Jesus opened up in the scroll
and scrolled to what He stood in the temple for the first time
and He read this.
And He said, these words are now fulfilled in me.
These words were written purposefully by the prophets
through the power of the Holy Spirit about Jesus Christ.
He is the one who has come to heal the broken hearted.
We need to bow before Him and ask for that healing.
I need Him.
You have been sent, Lord, to heal me.
Heal my broken heart.
Make me whole.
Make me see with your eyes.
Make me hurt over the things that you hurt over.
Make me weep over the things that you weep over.
Change my life from the inside out.
Give me that purpose so that I can start prayed a circle
and be a warrior for you here on earth.
By the blood of Jesus, I am free.
I am free from the slavery of sin, from condemnation.
I am free from condemnation.
I am free from guilt.
I am free from shame.
I am free from the ways and effects of death.
I have life in Jesus.
This is taken from Romans 8 and 2.
Where it says, therefore, there is now no condemnation
for those who are in Christ Jesus.
If you are living under a spirit of condemnation,
under a spirit of guilt, under a spirit of shame,
just turn it over to Him.
He does not condemn you.
He has forgiven you.
All is forgiven.
Turn your life over to Him.
And it is in you will be free.
And that is the desire for us for the law of the spirit
of life in Jesus Christ has set you free from the law of sin and death.
That is the beauty of the new covenant.
It all comes down to love.
I have ceased being a people pleaser and I am a God pleaser.
This is a big one for me.
If you are stuck in the same trap, you try to please other people
try to make everybody happy.
Well, Galatians 1 10 says, for I am now seeking the favor of men
or I seek the favor of God.
If I am striving to please men, if I were still trying to please men,
I would not be a mud servant of Christ.
You can't have it any other way.
I am going to go all out for God.
This is maybe why I am going through what I am going through.
It is just to break me to my knees.
It is to break me of myself.
It is to break me to Him.
It is to realize that there is anything un-earth worth holding unto
and it is for me to hold unto Him completely.
He desires for you just to crawl up at His lap and He wants to hold you
and cuddle you and take care of you and love you and say,
I have so much more for you than all the stuff that you have tried to accumulate
and all the games you have tried to play in order to be seed better
among your peers or among your family.
There is so much more for you.
Stop trying to chase those circles and come into my circle.
Wow, Jesus loved me enough to die for me so that He could live in me
and do His work of faith in me and through me.
I could do nothing without Him.
I am completely dependent upon Him.
I have stopped trying to do things in my own strength.
He is my strength.
This comes from Galatians 2.20 or it says, I have been crucified with Christ.
It is not I who live any longer but Christ lives in me in the life that I don't live in this flesh
because I still have this flesh.
I live my faith in the Son of God who loved me and gave Himself for me.
This is a verse that we should just grade into our hearts.
It is not I that live any more.
It is Christ that lives in me and I need to surrender to that on a daily basis
and allow Him to work through me.
And that is a beautiful verse.
But God be rich in mercy because of His great love with which He loved us
even when we were dead in credit's Christians.
He made us alive together with Christ.
By grace you have been saved and raised us up with Him
and seated us with Him in the heavenly places with Christ.
We are in our seated in the heavenly places with Christ.
That is where our spirit is.
We need to live like that.
No matter what circumstances we are going through, no matter what suffering we are dealing with,
we can turn it over to Him and know that He cares for us.
He went through this too and He is going through it with you right now.
My Father has forgiven me of all my sins by the blood of Jesus Christ.
That was done 2,000 years ago if you surrendered to Him.
It is a done deal.
My spirit, man, is alive and perfected in Jesus Christ.
Since God forgives me, I choose to forgive myself.
And that is a big one.
Especially if you grew up in the church where there is just so much guilt and shame
and guilt and shame and you will never measure up and you will never be good enough.
And you try, try, try so hard to be good enough and the bar is always raised.
You have already been forgiven.
It is a done deal.
There is nothing else that you could do to make God love you more.
Nor is there anything that you could do to make Him love you less.
He already loves you.
He shows you He picked you.
He consecrated you.
No, He was consecrated ourselves to Him.
We need to surrender ourselves wholly and completely to Him.
And say, Lord, I am done.
I am done trying.
I am done trying to be good.
I need your righteousness.
I cannot conjure it up in my own goodness or all my works.
I am going to trust completely, completely in you.
And that is really what it means to pray, prayer, circles.
We go from sadness in our circumstances to true joy.
We are talking about happiness.
Happiness has to do with our happenstance and happen to do it with judging our circumstances.
It has nothing to do with my circumstances.
Joy can be found.
Not in being healthy.
Not in being wealthy.
Not in having lots of friends and having our family all look perfectly.
Happy that a joy can only come through what is inside of us that we find in God.
That is a gift of the Holy Spirit.
And that is what we ask for.
Lord, give me joy in all my circumstances.
This is Paul could have joy and sing praise songs while he's sitting in a rotting Roman cell
where rats are biting at his feet.
And he's freezing cold.
Water is dripping from the walls in chains.
We can still sing praises because it has nothing to do with the circumstances.
It has everything to do with who is in his heart and who he is focusing on.
And we need help with that.
That's what these cards are for.
That's what our life is for us to be.
Is to draw these circles of prayer around us.
Draw a circle of prayer in your mind around yourself.
And say, Lord, keep me consecrated to you.
Keep me wholly devoted to you.
Keep me totally focused on you.
Keep me completely dependent upon you, Lord.
This is my prayer so that you fill me with your Holy Spirit.
So that I might flow out of me when people bump into me.
What spills out is the fruit of the Spirit is the peace and the patience and the joy and the love that others need.
That they need to see in me.
Let me be that.
Every day I fill myself up with myself.
And my prayer circle needs to be, Lord, I just spill it out to you.
I dump that out.
That is repentance.
I want to turn away from that.
Lord, I can't even do that without the power of your Spirit in my life.
So, Lord, I just surrender to you.
Dump out my flesh, my desires, my anger over that person.
Cutting me off in traffic by selfishness because that cashier isn't moving fast enough.
All my selfish thoughts, all my worries, all my strife, all my anxiety, all my depression.
Lord, I just spill it out to you.
I just dump it out to you.
Just fill my cup with your Holy Spirit that I might be filled with the fruit of the Spirit.
And that's what people see in me.
And that's what people receive in me when they forbid me because that's what spills out because that's what I'm received from you.
That's my initial prayer circle.
That should be your initial prayer circle.
Draw it around you.
Keep me consecrated and sanctified for your purpose only.
I draw another prayer circle around your family.
I spouse.
I'm going to pray these same things for my spouse.
I'm going to pray these same things for my kids.
I'm going to pray these same things for my home and for my church and for my community and for my neighbors.
For that person in your life who rubs you wrong, for that person in your life who's a struggle, who you can't get along with, who you don't like at all.
Prayer, a prayer circle around them and just ask God to do His work in them.
And thank God for the work that He's already doing in Him.
Maybe it's to rub you wrong, to drive you to your knees, to pray for that person.
There's a purpose in everything and if we believe that we serve a sovereign God, He is good and He is loving it all things, that even my difficult times, even my suffering has a purpose.
Lord, I surrender that to you.
I'm not concerned so much about getting rid of my suffering as much as I'm concerned about displaying you through my suffering.
That needs to be my prayer.
And let that be your prayer. Let that be where you draw your prayer circles.
Make these cards. Learn how to pray this way. Learn how to become a prayer warrior.
But Jesus looked at them and said, with men this is impossible, but with God, all things are possible.
It's not your efforts that's going to change the world.
But it's you focusing on what God wants to do with your life and allowing that to take place, allowing it no matter what circumstance you find yourself in, that you are more and more deeply surrendered to Him.
That you are in a greater dependence upon Him today than you were yesterday.
That is maturity. That's what maturity is.
Matured is in having all your ducks in a row and being holier by someone else's view from the outside in.
Matured is having a greater dependence upon God today than you had yesterday.
That's what maturity is.
I lay in Zion a chief quarterstone at his Jesus Christ, elect precious.
And he who believes, ad him, will by no means be put to shame, no matter what goes on in your life, that is your quarterstone.
Is your belief that God has suffered? He loves me and he has sent me apart to do this work.
And that's what I've chosen to do, no matter what my circumstances.
And this is one of my favorite verses, Matthew 5-3.
Blessed are the poor in spirit for theirs is the kingdom of heaven.
And what that really means, that word poor in the Greek is tokas' poor.
Blessed are the tokas' in tokas' is somebody who is completely utterly dependent, who is completely broken of themselves.
This verse speaks to me so much because it is only when you are completely emptied out.
It is when you are completely in a position of realizing that there is nothing possibly that you can do in yourself to please God, to be holy, to be righteous.
It is not about any of my works at all.
It is only when I am completely utterly dependent upon Christ.
When I realize that my spirit is nothing without Him that I can truly enter into the realization of what the kingdom of heaven is really all about.
I tend to be a fairly strong individual.
If I decide I am going to do something, I am just going to go do something.
I was always that way. I can do anything, so I will just do it.
And this is the verse that really broke me. This is the Holy Spirit used this verse to break me.
This is the first thing that Jesus preached publicly that is written in the Book of Matthew.
And I just find it quite interesting that he starts out speaking right to my heart that if you want a piece of the kingdom of heaven you have to realize you can't do it yourself.
It is all about understanding how utterly destitute you are in your spirit.
It is impossible to do it without me.
When you realize that, then it comes, it enters my kingdom because I am going to do great things through you.
But it is only when you consecrate yourself.
That is the act of sanctification and it is a daily basis and it never stops.
It is constantly dumping out your vessel and realizing that I need him and need him alone.
And it has nothing to do with my circumstances. It has nothing to do with my knowledge.
It has nothing to do with all the great things about me or all the weak things about me.
It is about how great our God is.
And that is the initial circle that we all need to come and draw around ourselves.
Lord, I can't do this. I can't do this.
I am completely dependent upon you.
And the more I focus on how sad I am or how sick I am or how much a victim I am or how great I am or how accomplished I am
or all the things I can do, the weaker I become.
And it is only when I come before you and go, Lord, I am an empty vessel.
Just take me, dump me out, fill me with your spirit so that I can do great things not so that I can get praised
but so that people can see you when they look at me.
That is my prayer.
And that is my prayer circle around you.
I want you to understand, as a patient here, we have prayed prayer circles around you.
And we are prayed for you daily.
And what of our prayer circles, our bigger prayer circles, is around this practice that everybody comes to us, will be healed.
And I don't mean that it is necessarily going to be a physical healing, though that is our prayer.
I want it to be a spiritual healing.
There is no way I would want to have patients come to me.
And to see them live ten years longer, it is still dying and going to hell.
That is not our purpose.
I want you, I want to see every single person up in the kingdom when I get there.
And I do want you to live longer.
I want you to glorify God at every part of your life.
That is our prayer circle around you.
I ask that you keep prayer circles around us as well.
Take this information, I do pray, that if it offended anybody, we will let it offend you because this is who we are.
And this is where we need to be.
Break that, let that break you down.
Take it home and let God do His work at you.
If this encouraged you, write these things down, and make it an action step in your life.
With that, we will close.
Thank you.